حسنًا ،
فلاديمير بوتين عبارة عن دورة ويجب أن
نكون واضحين بشأن ذلك
وسيذهب إلى أبعد ما نسمح له بالرحيل مثل
حلف شمال الأطلسي للولايات المتحدة ، فسوف تسمحون
له بالرحيل إنه متنمر يستمر في القول إن
لدي أسلحة وأنا أمتلك أسلحة نووية  ويمكنني
أن أفعل ما أريد القيام به
ولا يحتاج إلى استفزاز لأنه
يعتقد أساسًا أنه يمكنه فعل أي
شيء وهذا ما كان يفعله حتى الآن
في العالم الذي غزا فيه جورجيا ولم
يكن هناك رد فعل غزا
مولدوفا جزئيًا  ولم يكن هناك رد ، انظر
ماذا فعل في سوريا ، انظر ماذا فعل في
دول أخرى الآن هناك
إعدام علني لأوكرانيين
أمام العالم كله بصواريخ
روسية طائرات روسية من قبل الروس
وكنا نتوسل لحماية سمائنا
نحن لا نطلب القتال من أجلنا ، نحن
فقط نطلب
الحماية التقنية للسماء ، نحن نطالب
بفرض عقوبات أقوى
، ولسوء الحظ ، يتعين على العالم حتى هنا
الدخول في حل وسط ،
وسوف يفرضون عقوبات على روسيا  لكن مع
استبعاد قطاع الطاقة منه ، وهذا ما
يضعه بيت في جيشه
سيوقفونه سريعًا ، لكنهم تحولوا سريعًا
فقط بالنسبة لسبعة بنوك من أصل 300 بنك في
روسيا ، هذه عقوبات جزئية
ويتفهم بوتين أنه يمكنه الذهاب إلى أبعد من
ذلك.  يريد لأنه حتى في
القطاع المالي ليس هناك
رد فعل كافٍ ، فلنتحدث عن ،
أعلم أنك كنت في حريف منذ
بدء القصف هناك
فقط أخبرنا بما تراه على
الأرض وماذا تسمعه من
السكان هناك
صباح الخير أمريكا  شكرًا
لاستضافتي هنا ،
لم أتخيل أبدًا في أي كابوس أحلام سيء
أنني نجم موسيقى الروك الكبير الذي
يلعب في الملاعب في جميع أنحاء البلاد
في العالم سيذهب إلى
مدينة ألعب فيها الملعب
خلال العامين
الماضيين وأذهب إلى هناك خائفًا من أن أكون  قتلت
أو قتلت لترى
أه كيف تضررت هذه المدينة ومن ثم
لدعم الناس
وقوف السيارات تبدو وكأنها مدينة الحرب العالمية الثانية
أه وقوف السيارات يبدو وكأنه مدينة قصف من قبل
العدو الأكثر دموية بعد probab  لي ثلاث
سنوات من المواجهة وأنا لا
أبالغ في
مجلس المدينة ذهب
المجلس الإقليمي ذهب مركز
الشرطة الرئيسي ذهب
أه المستشفى ذهب
أه
العديد من الأحياء
بما في ذلك أه مجرد أحياء عادية
يعيش فيها الناس
أه
أحياء محتملة دمرت
العشرات  قُتل بما في ذلك
الأطفال والنساء ، وهو كابوس
لا أستطيع أن أتخيل أن عدوك هو
أن جارك الذي
دعا نفسه دائمًا ليكون أخًا ،
أعني
أنه أكبر جريمة لأنه
بدون أي يأس من الإقناع لأنه
يشعر بالشفاء روحياً  وعاطفيا
سيء جدا ولكن
من الناحية العسكرية من
جهة عسكرية أه كل المدافعين
والمسلحين أه الجيش واثق جدا
أنهم لن يستسلموا لن يتم
تطويقهم فهم مستعدون للدفاع
عن المدينة ويقولون الروس سيفعلون ذلك.
لا تأخذ ذلك أبدًا وأعتقد أنهم قد يفعلون ذلك